alles was du jetzt gerade um dich siehst
dein handy dein zuhause dich selber das
alles besteht aus normaler materie auch
alles was du jemals gesehen hast und
jemals sehen wirst alles was wir im
universum beobachten können alle
planeten und sterne bestehen aus dieser
normalen materie
dabei macht diese materie nur 4,9
prozent unseres universums auf 26,8
prozent sind dunkle materie sie
wechselwirkt über ihre schwerkraft mit
normaler materie und hält galaxien
zusammen ist aber so komplex dass sie
eigentlich ein eigenes video verdient
der großteil des universums besteht mit
68,3 prozent aber aus dunkler energie
ein phänomen das wir wieder wahrnehmen
noch messen oder irgendwie nachweisen
können
wir können nur den effekt auf das
universum beobachten denn dunkle energie
sorgt dafür dass sich das universum
ausdehnt galaxien und sternensysteme
driften auseinander wie rosinen in einem
aufgehenden teig und das nicht nur
gleichmäßig sondern immer schneller
wenn es so weitergeht dann stirbt unser
universum irgendwann den wärme tot
dann sind alle dinge im universum von
der dunklen energie so weit auseinander
gerissen worden dass nur noch leere und
dunkelheit herrschen
[Musik]
dieses video entstand in zusammenarbeit
mit dem pm magazin in der aktuellen
titelgeschichte des magazins geht es
auch um dunkle energie und wie
wissenschaftler versuchen sie zu
verstehen
durch die kooperation habt ihr die
möglichkeit an einem gewinnspiel von pm
magazin teilzunehmen und zwar gibt es zu
gewinnen eine djs back tone die ihr mit
euren händen steuern könnt und die
videos in 4k aufnehmen kann
wie ihr am gewinnspiel teilnehmen könnte
das erfahrt ihr am ende des videos
albert einstein wird heute als einer der
genialsten denker aller zeiten gesehen
doch auch er hat fehler gemacht oder
zumindest dachte er das 1915 stellte
einsteigen seine inzwischen berühmte
allgemeine relativitätstheorie vor
sie beschrieb das universum und seine
regeln in einer neuartigen nie
dagewesenen art und weise doch seine
formeln beschreiben ein universum das
entweder schrumpfen oder sich aus denen
muss nun war die vorherrschende meinung
in der physik zu dieser zeit aber dass
das universum stabil sei um seine
eigenen formeln also an diese meinung
anzupassen vollführte ein stein einen
trick er fügte die kosmologische
konstante allen sie sorgte dafür dass
das universum in einsteins formeln
gleich gross bleibt 14 jahre später
brach in den usa der aktienmarkt
zusammen aber astronomen edwin hubble
interessierte sich für größeres er
beobachtete nämlich benachbarten
galaxien und musste dabei feststellen
dass irgendetwas nicht stimmte das licht
das er beobachten konnte war ins
rötliche verschoben eine solche
rotverschiebung tritt auf wenn sich eine
lichtquelle von uns entfernt dabei
werden die wellen des lichts in die
länge gezogen wie ein krankenwagen der
an dir vorbei rast und tiefer klingt
sobald er sich von ihr entfernt
babbel stellte also fest alle galaxien
entfernen sich von uns egal wo wir
hinschauen alles scheint vor uns zu viel
sind wir also der mittelpunkt des
universums so sehr man die menschen das
auch von sich denken ist das natürlich
nicht so
der raum selbst dehnt sich aus alles
entfernt sich von allem für einstellen
war das natürlich ein schock
er hatte von anfang an recht gehabt
hätte er nur seinen formeln vertraut er
strich die kosmologische konstante
wieder und nannte sie die größte eselei
seines lebens doch das könnte voreilig
gewesen sein denn was man damals noch
nicht wusste ist dass sich das universum
immer schneller aus
lange zeit dachte man dass das universum
seit dem urknall expandierte die
gravitation der materie aber schon dafür
sorgen würde dass diese expansion
verlangsamt und irgendwann sogar
umgekehrt bis ich wieder alles zu einem
punkt verdichtet schließlich ziehen sich
alle dinge im universum gegenseitig
haben und wenn keine andere kraft auf
uns einwirkt dann sollten wir auf kurz
oder lang an schwung verlieren so dass
sich alles wieder näher kommt 1998
wollten zwei forschergruppen unabhängig
voneinander berechnen ob sich diese
expansion bereits verlangsamt und wenn
ja wie stark
[Musik]
dazu nutzen sie supernovae den tod eines
sterns um genau zu sein beobachteten die
forscher aus kalifornien und australien
supernovae vom typ 1a die explodieren
nämlich immer mit derselben energie für
astronomen ist das ein wahres geschenk
es ist so als könnte man ein und
dasselbe phänomen an vielen
verschiedenen orten im universum
beobachten wie hell uns die explosion
dann erscheint hat nichts mehr mit der
supernova selbst zu tun sondern nur
damit wie weit sie von uns entfernt ist
die forscher kalkulierten also die
geschwindigkeit und die entfernung
dieser supernovae jetzt zu uns die
geschwindigkeit mit hilfe der
rotverschiebung die entfernung mit hilfe
der helligkeit
das ist extrem kompliziert und aufwendig
deswegen waren sich die forscher zu
beginn auch sicher dass sie sich
verrechnet hatten
denn irgendetwas stimmt da nicht je
weiter eine supernova von uns entfernt
war desto stärker schienen die
rotverschiebung zu sein
diese messdaten zu distanz und
geschwindigkeit passten nicht zusammen
zumindest nicht in einem universum das
sich immer langsamer ausdehnt deswegen
überprüften sie immer wieder alles auf
fehler aber die daten waren korrekt die
einzige erklärung die expansion des
universums wird nicht immer langsamer
sie beschleunigt sich
einsteins kosmologische konstante seine
größte eselei wurde als lamm da wieder
in die formeln eingefügt dieses mal
nicht um das universum konstant zu
halten sondern um zu beschreiben dass
sich seine ausdehnung beschleunigt
durchgesetzt hat sich allerdings ein
anderer name für dieses phänomen dunkle
energie und viel weiter als das sind wir
heute noch nicht dunkel bezeichnet
nämlich keine eigenschaft sondern sagt
nur aus dass wir keine ahnung haben was
dieses phänomen ist genau wie mit
dunkler materie tappen wir im dunkeln
im grunde genommen wissen wir nicht
einmal ob es sich bei der dunklen
energie wirklich um energie im
klassischen sinne handelt sie lässt sich
mit unserem aktuellen verständnis der
physik nicht vereinen und es wird
wahrscheinlich ein größerer umbau der
physik nötig sein um die immer
schnellere expansion des universums zu
erklären denn dunkle energie scheint das
universum auszufüllen ihre dichte ist
sehr gering
in den meisten kontexten sogar
vernachlässigbar klein aber eben nicht
nur
und diese geringe energie die sich
überall im universum befindet reicht aus
um die gravitation
besiegen und das universum unaufhaltsam
aufzublähen
je weiter sich das universum ausdehnt
desto mehr dunkle energie gibt es alles
fliegt auseinander galaxienhaufen werden
den einzelnen galaxien verstreut
galaxien driften auseinander und werden
zu einzelnen sonnensystemen licht von
anderen galaxien wird immer deutlicher
und verlässt schließlich das sichtbare
spektrum weil sich diese immer schneller
von uns entfernen
irgendwann entfernen sich alle
lichtquellen mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit von uns und es
bleibt für immer dunkel in einem
möglichen szenario zerreißt die
ungebremste expansion des universums
sogar materie atome werden in ihre
einzelteile zerlegt es bleibt nur
strahlung in zehn hoch 106 jahren sind
selbst die größten schwarzen löcher
verdampft und ab dann ist nichts mehr
[Musik]
wie bereits am anfang angekündigt
veranstaltet das pm magazin ein
gewinnspiel bei dem ihr eine djs park
drohne gewinnen könnt die drohne ist
extrem kompakt bietet aber trotzdem eine
sehr gute bildqualität und eine menge
features zum beispiel lässt sich sowohl
mit dem smartphone als auch mit hand
gesten steuern
ziemlich cool und ein guter einstieg
falls sie schon immer mal drohnen
fliegen wollte
zusätzlich zu der chance auf diesen
hauptgewinn bekommt jeder teilnehmer der
möchte zwei gratis ausgaben des pm
magazins inklusive der aktuellen ausgabe
da drin steht noch viel mehr über das
rätsel der dunklen energie
und natürlich ist immer auch der rest
der ausgabe mit spannenden artikeln
gefüllt es geht darum wie wir unser
erbgut auslesen können was eigentlich 5g
ist und ab wann man eigentlich als
verrückt gilt den link zum gewinnspiel
und die teilnahmebedingungen findet ihr
unten in der video beschreibung
ansonsten wie immer vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig
[Musik]